what's up guys I'm in a car park right
now I am actually going to go run some
errands you're going to pick up a
limited edition Brompton to check out
for a couple days anyway I'm using the
fx30 that's why you're watching this
video was just announced I've actually
been using this camera for the past
couple weeks for a variety of projects
here on geek culture but I want to talk
to you guys about this camera what it's
like to use as a Daily Camera for
vlogging and for video I'm not going to
go through all the specs you've already
seen videos on that and there's also a
website but I'll talk to you about why I
absolutely love this camera there's a
variety of reasons and optimally if I
had a choice between this and the fx3 I
might go for this one of the things I
like about this camera person foremost
is the overall size now it is the same
as the fx3 with this aps-c or super 35
format sensor here you now can put in
smaller lenses which makes this ideal
for vlogging for videography and the
image quality is absolutely fantastic
it's been this way since I turned it on
I have been loving the image quality
coming out of this I have a variety of
lenses to test out but I'm using two
primarily this is the 1655 F 2.8 G lens
also the 11 1.8 which is great for
vlogging and I'll be switching to that
in just a bit but on the 1655 now just
for variety if I want to zoom in on some
stuff but anyway I can't shoot and drive
so off we go let's chat in a bit
quick stoplight chat F1 is about to
happen here so that's why all the roads
are getting barred off it's going to be
one badass week okay now I've switched
over to the 11 1.8 lens and I'm using
active study shots so there is a little
bit of a crop on this but it does make
it very usable for vlogging as a matter
of fact this is one of my favorite
lenses get a nice one point it's and get
a nice depth of field and with this
active steady shot crop in it is really
good for videoing yourself so as you can
tell image quality is great eye tracking
is fantastic and we're good to go so I'm
going to get out of here the car and
we're gonna go check out this limited
edition Brompton so let's talk about
this new sensor from Sony it's a 20
megapixel they're calling it an aps-c
sensor but when you shoot it in cinema
mode or video mode it goes to Super 35
it's kind of a hybrid sensor very
interesting I don't know if it's just a
pseudo a super 35 or it's actual super
35. I do have some limited information
on that but I mean nonetheless the image
quality is fantastic you've got all your
auto focusing is there phase detect
animal eye tracking all that is there
the same as the fx3
um it sticks on Like Glue I mean as you
can tell it's a very confident inspiring
camera because you didn't see any EI you
can shoot in a variety of different
formats as slog slog3 hlg all that it's
all on this camera so it's very
reminiscent of the fx3 except it is a
smaller sensor but the one cool thing is
when you do shoot photos you don't no
longer have to deal with a 12 megapixel
frame sensor you can have a 20 megapixel
aps-c image that you get to shoot photos
with but there is no mechanical shutter
all electronic shutter and it's only
single shot so if you want to do Burst
Mode you can't do it with that you've
got to use single shot or just press the
shutter button very very fast but there
is some rolling shutter see we'll see
some warping once in a while but if
you're just grabbing a still shot just
for you know helping with the video like
a thumbnail or just want to capture a
moment then it's perfect for that anyway
we're at Brompton right now e-bike right
here gotta have a license plate in
Singapore without the battery pack on
it's a standard c-line Brompton we can't
show this out of the box just yet right
until 5 p.m right I just want just so
the peek in
oh my God that's gorgeous it's like a
cream color where the gold Brompton
lettering with a Brooks saddle on it
this is
beautiful I can't wait to ride this
around oh thank you so much thank you
very much appreciate it thank you we're
in thanks Ethan
as you can see by the footage and just
by just general filming with this thing
it is very confidence inspiring the
autofocus on Sony's cameras are great
this fx30 is going to be a great B cam
for a lot of Cinema people out there but
even if you just want this as your main
camera for Content creation you're gonna
be very very happy with the results now
there is something to be said about
using aps-c lenses and the limitations
in that way because there's not as many
aps-c lenses that are faster lenses what
I mean is like F2 and Below versus the
full frame counterparts so yes you can
put you can put full-frame lenses on
this but you have to take into
consideration that crop factor that does
come into play if you want something
wide like what I'm using right now to
Vlog this 11 1.8 this is probably one of
the faster lenses out there there are a
lot of f4 power Zoom options out there
as well and I have some of those lenses
and I'll show you what they look like on
the fx30 I gotta say that just using
this camera daily
it's been really so enjoyable the color
science is really good on this I'm just
shooting standard I'm not even shooting
log right now I'll show you some sample
footage of shooting and log and all that
stuff but man and the price point is
actually not that bad I think it's
Singapore dollars it's around 27.99
without the uh the XLR handle on it and
then of course when you have that that's
a different story altogether but uh yeah
anyway off to my next meeting which is
to check out some PC builds
[Music]
oh
this is a cockpit by Martian gear this I
guess a full-on gaming rig right well
actually people use it for two purposes
one fully immersive gaming uh office is
great office rig yeah what's you know
you'd expect the arm to come down and
the cable come in as well whoa holy cow
this is crazy I like this I could see
myself working in this and it doesn't I
guess it it looks big but I guess it
wouldn't take up that much room right
it's not much more space than this right
desks are usually plus you know your
chair when you infected it in
this if you picked up more space wow so
this is what it looks like when it's
closing up
how cool is that
[Music]
all right so the bike is beautiful dream
core was absolutely awesome and I have
just thoroughly enjoyed the fx30 so
you're probably thinking are you just
gonna show us vlogging Bobby no here's
some sample footage that we've taken
over the past couple weeks with this
camera I'll come back with my final
thoughts
[Music]
thank you
but as you can tell this is great in low
light we were shooting in really dark
situations we were testing out this with
the iPhone 14 versus the xiaomi 12s
Ultra and myself and even Xeno were
really surprised by the footage of
course if you want to shoot this in log
like how we did for the Apple watch
Ultra you're gonna get some really good
footage out of that as well this is
going to be a very formidable camera for
a lot of people out there and I know
this is Sony's entry cinema camera but
to me this is a lot more than that this
is a perfect vlogging camera this is a
perfect go-to camera for traveling or
for Content creators out there that
don't want to break the bank and I would
say it'll probably rival the a7s3 and
the fx3 in many many ways it's a lighter
kit if you're okay with super 35 you're
going to really enjoy this some people
are hard set on full frame okay I get
you I was that person too but after
using the fx30 this provides me with
really great image qualities and if you
want to get into Cinema lenses there are
plenty out there for the super 35 format
that are going to blow your mind and the
effect 630 will perform beautifully on
it anyway those are my thoughts on the
camera let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below if you like this
video check out more of our reviews
right here
[Music]